the remarkable thing about note comp is
that it's always been the right thing
for the community at the right time this
is the first one I've been to and it's
fantastic you know I thought it was
going to be a like a summer camp style
event but it's a real summer Katrina you
can hear you can hear and see children
behind us there at camp right now if
we're just hanging out having a
conference is incredible I had I had
given up on conferences maybe six or
seven years ago the format doesn't work
for me you see it through a couple days
of presentation is usually five minutes
of the presentation I'm thinking about
something else from answering emails it
really surpassed my expectations the
fact that every every organized session
was hands-on the fact that every session
your meeting at people you sitting next
to somebody you're working with
so you're learning by doing as opposed
to listening and you're also getting to
know the people around you by working
with them as opposed to just talking
over a beer and then at the end of the
whole day you know there's all the
talking over the beer and around the
campfire and you know you can swap your
war stories because you're all working
on the same project at different kinds
or you know people are bragging about
the hacks they did and stuff like that
so
I got something substantial out of every
single session volunteer the ability to
have my family here in a really easy way
as this campground I brought my wife and
two kids and they really enjoyed it had
a lot of fun and I've got to hang out
with them in between sessions and
getting some lunches and things and
during the free diamond easily when my
favorite conferences it's just this
about community it's that family it's
about really cares about what wear this
like we just going and we want to do
with it and what can we do with it
and just seeing where it at work crowd I
think what's unique about no cop really
is that Michael really cares a lot about
doing a really good job and putting on
something really interesting that kind
of brings the community to get together
so yeah this this time was definitely
really really fantastic I mean having
everybody here I'd like in like
workshops you know to do something that
they thought they couldn't do in each
one of the sessions I think was really
impressive and you know I think a lot of
people like actually accomplished
something you know usually when you go
to a conference you like you get kind of
inspired yeah that's really cool and
then you go home and you take a nap and
you never don't think about so this time
I mean people are actually like getting
their hands dirty with stuff
you